we're on problem 71 and they ask us
which fraction is equivalent to this
thing 3x over 5 divided by x plus 4 over
x plus 2.
so the best way to do this let's
simplify the denominator first so that's
equal to 3x
over 5
all of that over let's see let's find a
common denominator the common
denominator is 4 right so that's
if we have a common denominator of 4 x
over 4 is of course x over 4
plus x over 2 is the same thing as 2x
over 4 right so plus 2x over 4 right 2x
over 4 is the same thing as x over 2.
and now if you divide by
if you divide by a certain fraction
that's the same thing as multiplying by
its inverse so this is going to be equal
to 3x over 5
times the inverse of this times 4
over x plus 2x
let's see what we could do well we could
factor out an x here so this becomes
this becomes x
times
one
one plus two actually one plus two is
three i just said x plus two x is equal
to three x i should have done that this
is that's silly i shouldn't have done
that i should have said x plus 2x is
equal to 3x
right x plus 2x is equal to 3x my bad
anyway 3x and 3x cancel out numerator
and denominator and you're just left
with four fifths
four fifths and that's choice c
it's getting late
next question
let me write let me copy and paste this
word problems it's good to
to parse these together
all right
okay
a pharmacist mixed some ten percent
saline solution with some fifteen
percent saline solution to obtain
hundred milliliters of a twelve percent
saline solution
okay how much of the ten percent saline
solution did the pharmacist use in the
mixture
okay so ten percent and fifteen percent
so let's say let t equal the amount of
ten percent so let's say amount
of 10 percent
and let's say that
f is equal to
the amount
of 15 solution i pick t t for 10 f for
15. okay so the amount of 10 percent
solution plus the amount of 15 percent
solution
that has to equal 100 milliliters well
we'll just assume we're dealing in
milliliters that equals 100
and then how much saline are we going to
end up with so if we have
the 10 percent saline solution is going
to contribute however
however much saline we have how much
saline is it going to contribute to the
hole well it's 10 percent saline so
we're going to contribute
10 of that as saline right so 10
times the amount of 10 solution tells me
how much saline i'm contributing
plus
times the amount
of the 15 saline solution i'm
contributing this is the amount of
saline from that solution
and that equals what now this is
interesting
you end up with a 12 percent saline
solution 100 milliliters of a 12 saline
solution so how much saline total am i
going to have when i mix it all together
i had 100 milliliters it's a 12 saline
solution so that means 12 percent of
this 100 milliliters is saline
so that equals 12. there's 12
milliliters of saline
with this much contributed from the 10
10 solution and that much contributed
from the 15 solution
so let's see what we can do so now we
have two linear equations and two
unknowns we're ready to solve
so the best thing to do i want to cancel
out what do they want to know they want
to know how much of the 10
saline solution so the best thing we
want to cancel out the f's somehow and
solve for t
so let's multiply this top equation
times minus 0.15 because i want to
cancel this out with this so let's do
that if we multiply times minus 0.15
we end up with
minus 0.15
t
f
is equal to
minus 15.
and then
if we add these two equations 0.1
plus minus 0.15 that's
minus
0.05
right right that's right
t
these two cancel out it's equal to 12
minus 15 is minus three
okay we can multiply both sides by
negative one you get plus .05 is equal
to times t is equal to three
and sorry i'm getting messy here so
let's you divide both sides by 0.05 you
have t is equal to 3 divided by that's a
3.
3 divided by 0.05
0.05 that's that's the same thing as
120. so this is equal to 3 times 20
which is equal to 60. so we contributed
60 milliliters
of the 10 saline solution so t is equal
to 60 in this choice a and this is a
little bit confusing because you know
you're like oh what variable i use for
the 10 solution and how do i set up the
second equation and a good place to
start say oh well they want to know how
much of the 10 saline solution did the
pharmacist use so let me set that as a
variable
let me set another variable for the
other type of solution if i add them
together i have to get 100 milliliters
and then the tricky part was just
probably figuring out okay how much
saline did each of the solutions
contribute and then when you add that up
that equals 12 milliliters of saline
anyway
next question
next question 73
go
andy's average driving speed for a
four-hour trip
was 45 miles per hour during the first
three hours he drove 40 miles per hour
what was his average speed for the last
hour of a strip
okay so distance is equal to rate times
time
distance is equal to rate
times time
okay so they his total and for a
four-hour trip
was 45 miles per hour or you could say
rate is equal to distance divided by
time
right that's just divide both sides of
that by time so he said the average
driving speed for four hour trip was 45
miles per hour so 45 miles per hour
is equal to the distance he traveled
divided by his time divided by four
hours so we can figure out the distance
right off the bat so let's actually do
that so distance is equal to 4 times 45
distance is equal to 45
times 4 that's what 40 times 4 is 160
plus 5 times 100 so it's equal to 180
what is it miles
the distance is equal to 180 miles
d is equal to 180
miles fair enough they say during the
first three hours he drove 40 miles per
hour
during the first okay what was his
average speed for the last hour of his
trip so we just have to figure out how
much ground did he have to cover so
during the first three hours
he drove 40 miles per hour so how long
how far did he go if you go so this so
that's a different distance that's just
the first three hours so the distance
over the first three hours
is equal to the rate of the first three
hours it's equal to 40
times the time times three hours
so his distance over the first three
hours equal to 120 miles
so how far did he have to travel in that
last hour well the first three hours he
went 120 miles he went a total of 180
miles so his distance
in that last hour
is going to be 180 minus 120 he had to
go 60 miles
in that last hour
right so how fast did he go well he went
60 miles in that last hour so he went 60
miles per hour
choice b
so this might seem like a complicated
problem and it is a little tricky but
it's all about distance equal rate times
time and then recognizing that the
second statement
that you could use this first statement
to figure out the total distance he
traveled you could use the second
statement to figure out how far he
traveled in the first three hours
and then you know how far he had to
travel in that last hour or essentially
how fast he had to travel
next question
74.
one pipe can fill a tank in 20 minutes
so say pipe one
its rate is equal to one tank
one tank
per 20 minutes
for 20 minutes that's how i like to
write that's why they told us one pi one
pipe can fill a tank in 20 minutes while
another takes 30 minutes to fill the
same tank so pipe two
is equal to one tank per 30 minutes
that's its rate
or 1 30th tank per minute this is 120 at
the tank per minute fair enough
how long would it take the two pipes
together to fill it so their combined
rate is just both of these right if you
have both pipes going in you're going to
have
1 20th
tank per minute
plus 1 60th
let's see
one twentieth plus one sixtieth common
denominator is sixty
one twenty is three sixty plus one
sixtieth is
one sixtieth tanks per minute just
adding fractions
so that equals four
sixtieth tanks per minute
which is equal to what four over sixty
four sixty that's one over fifteen
tanks per minute
so one over fifteen tanks per minute or
you could view this as equal to one tank
per 15 minutes
so how long does it take to fill one
tank 15 minutes
choice is c
choice is
c
problem oh i'm all out of time i'll see
you in the next video